prémat satellit startet heute nacht
alles rund um den stadtpark 36 vj 1
jetzt blickt fonds entwickeln heute
nacht ist es soweit nach einer und elf
monatigen testphase darf der mit
deutschem knowhow entwickelte
telekommunikationssatellit 36 wie einst
seine reise ins weltall antreten ort des
geschehens ist mal wieder der
weltraumbahnhof kourou in
französisch-guyana der für heute nacht
geplante start ist einer der ersten
versuche deutschland mit dem in bremen
ansässigen systemhaus ohg systems ag
wieder fuß im weltraum business zu
fassen die tagfahrleuchten 321 ist der
erste telekommunikations verbindet der
von ohg in enger abstimmung mit eva und
hispasat komplett konzipiert entwickelt
integriert und getestet worden ist
die bei jedem ersten mal sind wir auf
einer reihe technische herausforderung
gestoßen die für zufriedenheit der
kunden zu lösen galt die oha b team
fahren daher im bisherigen
projektverlauf viel gelernt und können
das ohg know how erweitern alle
erkenntnisse werden wir bei unseren
zukünftigen satelliten projekten sowie
bei den künftigen telekommunikation
verbündeten der mall die familie zu
nutzen wissen so perez von der ohg
systems ag in einer höhe von 36.000
kilometern erreicht hat extras wie einst
dann seinen vorgesehenen standort und
bereichert ab dann vorerst für 15 jahre
die iberische halbinsel die kanarischen
inseln und südamerika mit
multimedia-diensten übrigens soll mit
dem staat auch ein neuer markt
bereichert werden der markt der
leichteren und kleineren das erlitten
was meint ihr wird es irgendwann voll da
oben droht eine katastrophe wie im
spielfilm graffiti in denen es eine
kettenreaktion nicht zerstören da
satelliten gibt sagt mir eure sicht der
dinge dazu gerne in den kommentaren da
und ansonsten wenn euch das video
gefallen hat genau dafür einen daumen
nach oben da lassen und ein kostenloses
aber dafür genau da klicken da gibt
übrigens auch in ein anderes spannendes
video vom blick würde ich mal sagen
was würde ich sagen bis dann bleib dran
genau